gigantischer kampfroboter tobacco der
zukunft und one way ticket zum mars das
sind drei der fünf themen in den krieg
zum top news es ist vielleicht der
größte fortschritt in sachen
akkutechnologie das kotelett von huawei
arbeitet derzeit an einem akku der
zukunft der 3000 milliamperestunden akku
können innerhalb einer ladezeit von fünf
minuten zur hälfte aufgeladen werden 1
600 media stunden akku in zwei minuten
zu knapp 70 prozent
das ganze hat das wort crap auch
demonstriert es ist also keine
fantasiegeschichte oder graue theorie
zum vergleich das iphone 6 hat eine
akkuleistung von rund 1800
milliamperestunden und kann in einer
halben stunde je nach akku ladegerät zu
30 bis 40 prozent aufgeladen werden der
entscheidende unterschied zu
herkömmlichen akkus sind hetero atome
das sind in organisch chemischen
verbindungen atom und die keinen
kohlenstoff oder wasserstoff sind also
zb sauerstoff stickstoff schwefel und so
weiter diese atome werden an das graphit
in der anode des akkus angelagert also
an der positiven elektrode sie dienen
als katalysator für das lithium ein
katalysator ist ein stoff der chemische
reaktion beschleunigt ohne dabei
verbrauch zu werden so konnte die
reaktion im akku deutlich beschleunigt
werden ohne dass die energiedichte oder
die lebensdauer des akkus beeinträchtigt
wurde einziger wermutstropfen wann der
akku auf dem markt kommt das konnte
huawei noch nicht sagen
millionen kubikmeter große schleim masse
mitten im meer nahe jungen und sangen im
nordpolarmeer stießen wissenschaftler
bei einer erprobung einer fischfang
technik auf eine riesige schleim masse
zitat so etwas habe ich noch nie gesehen
so der wissenschaftler der universität
der arktis in trance oder lasen die
masse erstreckt sich über rund 200 meter
und würde sich teilweise bis zum grund
ziehen den forschern zufolge seien es
mehrere millionen kubikmeter die frage
woher kommt bzw aus was besteht der
schleim kann derzeit noch nicht 100
prozent beantwortet werden in einem
bericht des online-portals local wird
eine der forscherinnen zitiert es
handelt sich vermutlich um abgestorbene
oder
teilweise abgestorbene qualm sagte die
forscherin tone falken haug obwohl der
schleim unheimlich künstlich aussieht
haben wir menschen damit also wohl erst
mal noch nichts zu tun es sei denn wir
sind für das absterben verantwortlich
heute wollen wir euch ein faszinierendes
video zeigen dieses mal von einem
riesigen roboter der roboter ist nicht
da um alltägliches zu erledigen er soll
vielmehr als gladiator der neuzeit
dienen das unternehmen mega bots möchte
mit ihren robotern eine neue
unterhaltsame sportart ins leben rufen
wie die roboter aussehen und was sie
können das seht ihr jetzt
das ist ein wirklich spektakulärer fund
ein schweizer bauer hat etwas sehr
beeindruckend auf seinem land gefundene
römische münzen und nicht nur eine
handvoll sondern mehr als 4000 stück
aktuell untersuchen kantons archäologen
aus aargau den spektakulären von zitat
so etwas erlebt man als archäologe
selten mehr als einmal im berufsleben so
georg mata warum die münzen so besonders
sind sie sind zum einen in einem sehr
guten zustand und zum anderen stammen
sie aus der zeit berühmtester kaiser ja
und warum sie in einem so guten zustand
sind das können sich die experten nur
folgendermaßen vorstellen zitat der
besitzer muss sie gezielt ausgesucht
haben um sie zu horten denn das in ihnen
enthaltene silber garantierte in der
damals wirtschaftlich unsicheren zeit
wohl einen gewissen wert erhalt soko
doppler trauten die römer also schon
mehrere hundert jahre vor christus ihrem
banker nicht verübeln kann man es ihnen
jedenfalls nicht der film der marsianer
hat seinen zuschauern eine
beeindruckende vision der möglichen mars
besiedelung gezeigt auch wenn mal schnee
letzten endes alleine und nicht ganz
freiwillig den roten planeten besiedeln
musste kam an der realen vorstellung auf
dem mars zu leben erstaunlich nahe
robert schröder derzeit student möchte
sich das leben auf dem mars nicht mehr
länger vorstellen er will da hin und das
auch wenn es ein one-way-ticket gibt
zitat die idee auf dem mars etwas mit
einer kuh zu erreichen das bestand hat
für immer
das wäre das ober gaucho schulter die
niederländer wollen das jetzt bald
realität werden lassen ihr projekt
maßnahmen sollte eigentlich schon
nächstes jahr starten so schnell geht es
jetzt aber wohl doch nicht in den
nächsten zehn jahren soll es aber
losgehen experten sind von dem ganzen
vorhaben nicht gerade angetan zitat eine
one way mission ist unethisch so johann
dietrich wörner direktor der
europäischen raumfahrtagentur esa was
haltet ihr von solch einer mission
unethisch oder vielleicht auch nicht
würdet ihr euch auf solch eine mission
begeben
lasst es uns in den kommentaren wissen
und vergesst nicht den kanal zu
abonnieren ist kostenlos und ansonsten
bis dann bleibt dann und jetzt das
nächste video gucken